let's begin this hour with our series
protecting the planet which this morning
focuses on one of the most prolific
conservationists in the world a stunning
new documentary called Wildlife follows
the Journey of Chris Tompkins the former
CEO of the Outdoor Clothing Company
Patagonia she's on an inspiring mission
to save Wilderness areas in the
Patagonia region at the southern end of
South America senior National
Environmental correspondent Ben Tracy
sat down with Tompkins and filmmakers to
talk about her epic life story
come on dad keeping up with Chris
Tompkins is not easy well I can tell
you've spent many an hour in a kayak
because I'm just trying to keep up with
you here no no no and here on the urban
waterways of Austin Texas her mind
floats to something much bigger and much
farther away if you just
focused on that bank that West Bank
you'd think oh we're in the middle of a
national park
[Music]
Tompkins knows a lot about national
parks for three decades she's helped
create or expand 15 of them in South
America's Patagonia region protecting
nearly 15 million acres of land that
likely would have been lost to Mining
and logging why is it so important you
have to protect the lungs of the world
we can't use up
every square inch of this planet
worldwide we are losing Wilderness at
the rate of 27 million Acres a year just
in the tropics that's equivalent to 10
soccer fields every minute you have to
make space
for non-human life and once you decide
that that's the kind of person you are
your life has changed
Chris Tompkins life changed back in 1973
when she began working with her friend
Yvonne chenard at his little-known
climbing equipment company and then we
started making clothes and that became
Patagonia company she was patagonia's
first CEO for 14 years until she met and
fell in love with Doug Tompkins who also
knew a little something about clothes he
was the co-founder of the North Face and
later Esprit he left the fashion
industry in the early 90s and convinced
Chris to join him in Chile I'm going to
leave my rule as CEO I retired and two
days later on Sunday with two little
bags I closed up my beach house and
moved to to a roadless area on the coast
of Chile God went on life that journey
is the subject of the new documentary
film Wildlife it Chronicles how Doug and
Chris Tompkins devoted much of their
lives and well to buying up vast tracts
of land in Patagonia and pretty soon we
had the makings of a park they never
intended to keep the land for themselves
through Tompkins conservation they
became two of the largest private
landowners in the world protecting what
Chris Tompkins calls the crown jewels of
Patagonia for everyone to enjoy it's the
same way we feel about any land we've
ever conserved this has never been the
Chris and Doug story it was all about
love but the Chris and Doug story is the
heart of the documentary by filmmakers
Jimmy chin and chai vasarelli the
husband and wife Duo behind the
oscar-winning film free solo about famed
El Capitan climber Alex Honnold we make
films about people achieving The
Impossible Yellowstone National Park is
the biggest National Park in the United
States that's two million Acres
they preserved at this point 15 million
Acres Doug he had this audacious vision
of these parks and he happened to fall
in love with a great CEO who could like
execute this stuff really well how you
doing Chris
I'm okay chin and vasarelli are close
friends with most of the people in the
film and Doug Tompkins was Chin's
climbing Mentor I felt more pressure in
making this film than any film I've made
when you're making a film about your
Heroes you better get it right I've
always wanted to make a film about a
strong female protagonist and Chris is
that in Spades and I think especially
when her third act came you know you
really see a woman find her voice they
took the Zodiac out but that third Act
was born from tragedy Douglas Tompkins
died Tuesday in an accident in Chile dog
Tompkins was killed in a kayaking
accident in 2015. and then we flew him
the next day leaving Chris shattered
thank you for coming
is there something you've learned about
yourself that maybe you might not have
had you not lost your husband losing
Doug
was the worst thing it happened to me in
the shadow of that you realize you have
no fear and that makes you absolutely
free
to take on anything that fearlessness
has fueled her work 2.3 million now
we're talking
securing even more land and helping
re-wild it with Native species including
Pumas and jaguars
and in 2018 Chris Tompkins handed over
land for five more national parks to the
President of Chile you should be so
proud one of the largest private land
donations in history
what were you feeling in that moment as
you were saying okay here you go
it was
purest sense of Joy I think I ever have
experienced I love Urban Parks they're
the jewels of the Cities
Tompkins saw the documentary for the
first time last month at the South by
Southwest Festival in Austin and at age
72 she says she still has a lot more
work to do my intention is to do this
work until I drop dead so we're just
getting warmed up that's how I feel for
CBS mornings I'm Ben Tracy in Austin
wow Chris Tompkins my new hero I can't
wait to see that documentary yeah I mean
there's an incredible level of spiritual
enlightenment when she says you know you
realize you have no fear and that makes
you absolutely free to do anything it's
true you have no fear when you go
through something really horrific to you
personally and you survive it it does
make it does give you a different kind
of fierceness that you probably didn't
even know you had and they're not making
any more land so the fact that she has
the land and she's donating it to very
good causes I think she's amazing you
think of the Majesty is Yellowstone Park
yeah the size of it and what she's
talking about is magnitude's larger
right Yellowstone 15 million Acres it's
amazing and when she said giving the
land guys she said it gave her the
purest sense of Joy may we all do that
give something that makes us feel that
way makes you want to go hiking does
Miguel done well done bench racing I
actually enjoy hiking I don't look good
doing it I go to Instagram I actually do
like yeah I was hiking skills you do
live for yourself report back to us uh
Wildlife opens inside black theaters
starting tomorrow